he's my Segway and I know you guys are
familiar with the logs well you have met
the logs before where you're familiar is
another question I guess so you've met
these before and I think if I just say
correctly you're quite good at
manipulating them but I don't
necessarily think especially based on
the conversations I've been working that
I've seen around here you just really
understand the concepts really well and
that's where we're going okay so my
segue into it is to remind you of these
guys we spent a long time looking at
training and all of the different
results and focusing yeah okay
now this of course is the cosine wrong
okay now the interesting thing about the
cosine rule far more interesting and
useful than the sine rule I feel do you
just make thing about it is that as you
know it has two completely different
forms and you are familiar with this you
know they're trivially different you can
get from one to the other very very
easily okay but the point is well I
guess the question is why do we have two
forms of this formula we don't have two
forms for like area of a circle we don't
have two forms for volume of a sphere or
any other formula really you know even
the same until all you do is just turn
it upside down okay why do we have two
forms of the Kusum
yes yeah fantastic gonna be there again
we use the different folders which are
the same formula based on what we're
trying to find right what would you use
the top one
if you try and find a side and on both
side and here use it if you can't find
another angle
simple enough okay but this idea is
really crucial it will help you
understand why we have indices and bugs
why do we even have these things that
the same thing just looked at for
another angle right here's the point
what you see an equation every equation
is answering a question based on key
Madonna okay every question is doing
that but these to help you see that you
can use the same idea to ask different
questions based on what you know so what
you drop this down just you do this
right but what should I understand
what's going on here this left hand side
the subject of the equation this is what
you want this is what you're trying to
evaluate right it's like I want to go
with the Incas or I want to go with the
site is that you choose the appropriate
one that's the subject on the left hand
side of the right hand side you don't
have what you want you have what you
doors that's what you've got already and
you use that to do the left hand side
right so you've got what you want and
what do you know okay so if you've got
all three sides you can find out what
the angle is okay and vice versa for the
other things now that is why that will
help you understand what's going on with
indices and laws right I'm going to
write the same equation twice just like
this but what I write in different forms
now I'm gonna use some letters that are
they seem a bit random but you'll see
why I'm gonna do them in a second so
first you write this equation s equals
out of power tape okay you're like where
do those letters come from you'll find
out in a minute
if I were to write this same equation a
big back in index sorry in Log form how
would I write this same question what
would the subject of the equation B it
would be T
is the power right T is equal to Lord
now what what goes what where okay so
the way I remember it is the base here
of being the base yeah okay I think you
only got one of the piece you're done
okay now applying this idea of every
equation asking posing a question and
answering it based on even da da what
are these questions one of these
equations trying to tell you this is the
way I look at it obviously these are
very versatile equations they can apply
to many many different kinds of
questions but the overarching idea here
is that s RT stand for size right and
time let me explain okay if I gave you
like actual numbers here okay so example
right don't use a nice number it's to
sort of power off so this is Aidid that
if you are growing at this rate so
you're doubling right every every period
of time you're whatever object you've
got is doubling like a population or
like I've know an interest rate or
something like that okay
and if you're going for this amount of
time four five times five years five
centuries whatever it is then you will
be 32 times bigger your size your
relative size is 32 times bigger than
where you started
does that make sense right so the
question this is asking is how big
that's that's the question it's asking
very simple question ignasi's are
answering the question I think you
something right so being that these two
equations are the same equation looked
at from different angles just like this
is right now what I've got here is time
as the subject this is still the rate
over here and this is still the size
right so this equation is no longer
asking how big instead it asked him
how long right it's a time question it's
asking what duration will they take
let's rewrite the same you know the twos
of the Flies ability right same question
here okay
T was five was it it was the index right
fine that's log base two of 32 so this
is asking right you find doubling and I
do it five times I do it for five time
periods this is how big of a this is
asking if I'm doubling and I want to end
up thirty-two times bigger than I
started how long shall I do that and the
answer is five years five time periods
whatever it is okay question so you're
asking about like the rate is that what
you're asking
well it's a good question I think I
think historically the reason why is
because these are the questions that we
want to aren't and we don't have a lot
of power over the rate right the rate is
what it is you know a population is
growing it's such a such and such a
thing well it depends I think in general
you know day to day situations where
people are trying to solve problems the
rate is a it's a quantity that we have
no control over